schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute live
wir müssen zurück und zurück gucken auf
das wochenende dann an mehreren orten in
deutschland kam es bei protesten gegen
die korona maßnahmen zu gewalt in greiz
in thüringen zum beispiel wurden am
samstag 14 polizisten verletzt und auch
in sachsen und baden württemberg kam es
zu gewaltsamen auseinandersetzungen und
deshalb stellen wir heute hier die frage
wie radikal sind diese corona proteste
inzwischen geworden und wie weit gehen
radikale ins gegner und ins gegnerinnen
denn leider und den gab es natürlich
auch gibt es auch immer wieder
friedlichen protest aber der wurde jetzt
am wochenende überschattet von diesen
ereignissen und wenn ihr fragen oder
kommentare habt könnt ihr die wie immer
direkt in den stream stellen oder auch
per mail an uns schicken an die
e-mailadresse die wir euch gleich
einblenden und auch online wird gehetzt
und gedroht gegen politikerin politiker
oder auch impfärzte und impfärzte innen
und wir haben uns unter anderem heute
ein journalist eingeladen arndt ginzel
er hat für unsere sendung zdf sendung
frontal kontakt zu einer telegramm
gruppe aufgenommen die sich dort also
organisiert und die sich also auch zu
protesten organisiert und die vor allem
dort auch plant gegen politiker
gewaltsam vorzugehen und sie anzugreifen
und jetzt hier sehen wir noch bilder von
den angesprochenen protesten vom
wochenende
jetzt gerade hier bei uns im fenster
neben mir also hier sehen wir die
ausschreitungen die ich angesprochen
hatte und warum wir das also heute auch
zum thema machen und jetzt wollen wir
aber sprechen mit arndt ginzel der mir
jetzt zugeschaltet ist und den film
gemacht hat für frontal und ich hab's
angesprochen du bist also in diese
telegramm gruppe irgendwie reingekommen
hast du also auch länger beobachtet mit
wem hast du da gesprochen was was du da
erlebt
ja das war ja eine gemeinschafts
recherche mit dem kollegen henrik merker
der recht früh schon eingestiegen ist in
das thema über langen zeitraum dort
unterwegs war anonym
wir haben ihn immer den stillen hans
genannt weil das natürlich immer so ein
problem man darf da möglichst wenig
wenig sagen man muss da zu hören
und das heißt wir dann beim auswerten
festgestellt haben der materialien die
er da dokumentiert hat man sieht eben
wirklich eine sich steigernde
gewaltbereitschaft bei den leuten
dass das geht los dass man am anfang
überlegt wie kann man infektionen
sabotieren und endete letzten endes
darin oder gipfelte darin dass man pläne
geschmiedet hat wie man den
ministerpräsidenten von sachsen am
morgen kann
das war natürlich schon eine sehr heikle
situation
opfer potenzielle opfer waren auch im
teams die man angreifen wollte wo man
genau solche tötungsfantasien auch
geäußert hat polizisten ganz klar wo man
überlegt hat wenn ich auf eine demo gewo
stecke ich das messer hin um möglichst
wirkungsvoll zuzustecken zuzustechen
also von der verbalen gewalt über das
was man eben auch schon kennt aus
anderen sozialen medien antisemitismus
verschwörungs geschichten bis hin eben
zu ganz klar
mordfantasien mord planung das ist das
was wir dort erlebt haben und genau auch
von diesen tötungsfantasien also habt
ihr auch audioaufnahmen du und dein
kollege henrik merker und wir haben das
jetzt auch hier und hören mal kurz rein
perfect line treffen gesagt
benutze präsidenten ab sollten
es wissen muss ich entscheide ich bereit
für sein opfer
[Musik]
einen typen
falls sie irgendwo auf
und so weiter
mordpläne gegen den sächsischen
ministerpräsidenten michael kretschmer
von radikalen impfgegnern formuliert auf
telegramm
das was wir gerade gehört haben das war
aus dieser telegramm gruppe die ihr euch
zutritt verschafft habe dresden
vernetzung nennt die sich der ist das da
genau was das für leute
also den mann den man als erstes
sprechen hören hat der nennt sich daniel
wir wissen dass er irgendwo in heidenau
das ist ein vorort von dresden arbeitet
in einem betrieb ich glaube
zerspanungsmechaniker ist der hat sehr
viel preisgegeben über sich
und wir haben inzwischen fotos gefunden
von ihm die ihnen auch auf corona
demonstrationen zeigen er ist auf
bereits im vorfeld immer wieder
auffällig geworden in dem er aggressiv
auf fotografen auf journalisten reagiert
hat
dass
bei den anderen genau dasselbe also
immer noch andere personen wieder
gefunden die dort in dieser gruppe sich
bewegen das sind alles leute die schon
im vorfeld im frühjahr auch schon in auf
kroner demonstration
marschiert sind die kommen aus der szene
sind hoch radikalisiert und
ich habe den eindruck dass sie das
glauben dass sie wirklich daran glauben
dass es hier eine ganz große
verschwörung gibt gegen die menschen und
die wirklich gewillt sind ja mit gewalt
dagegen vorzugehen das ist der eindruck
den wir gewonnen haben und inwieweit
geht es da auch überhaupt noch im
protest gegen jetzt vielleicht corona
beschränkung oder maßnahmen und wer
vielleicht geht es geht ja um was ganz
anderes da auch schon inzwischen
da geht es schon lange um etwas anderes
was wir auch immer wieder gehört haben
war wir gehen auch keine demonstrationen
mehr quer denken ist uns zusammen das
sind verräter
nur wir wollen weitergehen es bringt
nichts mehr zu demonstrieren wir haben
versucht vergangenes jahr den bundestag
zu stürmen so in etwa also viele von
denen waren auch vergangenes jahr da in
berlin mit dabei auf mehreren extrem
gewaltsamen protesten und den geht es um
mehr den geht es darum den staat mit den
institutionen die demokratie mit ihren
institutionen und den vertretern darum
die anzugreifen so wie man das auch
schon bei anderen rechts terroristischen
organisationen erlebt hat ich erinnere
daran
revolution chemnitz wo man ähnliche
äußerungen gelesen hat den bürgerkrieg
auslösen wollte oder eben ja auch bei
tätern wie stefan ernst dem klub garten
täter auch dort wird man sowas finden in
dem was überliefert ist und ihr habt
nicht nur online dabei zugehört oder
auch teilgenommen bei den treffen
sondern ihr seid tatsächlich auch zu den
realen treffen von diesen menschen hin
gefahren habe dort auch gefilmt und habe
sie konfrontiert und da hören wir jetzt
auch und schau mal kurz rein
sie wollen ja ministerpräsidenten
umbringen
nützt das hatte er so formuliert
rausholen aus dem haus und dann oft
hängen haben sie ja gesagt
[Gelächter]
naja war damit war das jetzt nur eine
gewalt fantasie oder oder oder ich
sorgte zunächst keinen kommentar weil
das ist strafbar was sie da machen
wir vielleicht noch jemand was sagen zum
telegramm kanal
wieso wollen sie politiker am morgen
keine antwort am tag darauf wird der
telegramm kanal nicht mehr öffentlich
einsehbar sein der administrator hat ihn
auf privat gestellt
wir haben wir da gerade gesehen mit wem
gesprochen wurde war dass der
administrator oder was war das für eine
szene
das ist ich würde mal sagen
die die die linke hand des
administrators diesem mann haben wir
mehrfach gesehen mit dem administrator
der administrator selbst ist auch im
bild der irrlichtert dort permanent um
uns herum trägt so eine lederjacke den
haben wir als daniel identifiziert
und das sind die beiden ja für uns
ziemlich wichtigen personen
in dieser gruppe sind die dann auch in
irgendwelchen konntet ihr das vielleicht
auch herausfinden in irgendwelchen
parteien aktiv oder gibt es dann auch
weitere verbindungen zu anderen gruppen
also parteien dass das dass das ist ja
jetzt müsste man über längeren zeitraum
ja es gibt immer wieder auch
sympathiebekundung wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere richtung afd
verbindungen personeller art haben wir
eher so richtung freie sachsen gesehen
dass der person in dem telegramm kanal
drin waren die zumindest dieses logo der
freien sachsen im profi bild hatten da
gibt es einen sicherlich ein austausch
von einzelnen telegramm teilnehmern in
dieser gruppe das hat man das hat man
wirklich gesehen aber im wesentlichen
wie gesagt lehnen diese leute parteien
schon inzwischen ab die den unsere
unsere demokratie ab und da passt das
natürlich nicht dass man noch an wahlen
oder in parteien glaubt also die wollen
wirklich also es war unser gefühl die
wollen wirklich einen schritt weiter
gehen
zur einordnung kurz die freien sachsen
wird er angesprochen also rechtsextreme
kleinstpartei die zum beispiel dass es
spannend auch heute abend wieder über
telegramm aufgerufen haben das in
mehreren städten bis zu 100 sollen seien
in sachsen also jetzt auch wieder heute
abend protestiert werden soll wir werden
darüber später in der sendung noch
sprechen ich wollte aber gerne noch
fragen werden am ende auch des beitrags
gehört der kontakt ist dann quasi
abgerissen weil die telegramm gruppe
dann für euch auch nicht mehr einsehbar
war wie gefährlich ist denn da
vielleicht auch telegramm dass es ein
jahr einen nährboden und auch eine form
von untergrund bietet für menschen um
sich mit solchen fantasien halt zu
vernetzen
also ich halte das für sehr
problematisch
es haben sich halt dort gruppen gebildet
die
sagen wir sehr insofern sehr geschlossen
sind als das wenn man einmal drin ist in
dieser gruppe sehr schlecht wieder
rauskommt ich habe auch mit kollegen
gesprochen wir haben mal wieder darüber
nachgedacht es hat schon was
sektenartige also ich bin mir manchmal
gar nicht mehr so richtig sicher ob man
ob man nicht weiterkommt wenn man wenn
man wenn man sozusagen die merkmale ob
er nicht weiter käme wenn man die
merkmale in der sekte dort anlegt ich
meine wir hatten diesen vater in
brandenburg der seine familie
ausgelöscht hat vor kurzen und sich
selbst
weil er angst hatte dass ein gefälschtes
sein gefälschtes zertifikat irgendwie
bekannt werden würde mittlerweile
kapiere ich was so passiert es sind dort
audio nachrichten unterwegs in diesen
gruppen wo ein szenario geschildert wird
wo menschen die in dieser blase gefangen
sind und die vielleicht auch eine
gewisse neigung haben wirklich glauben
wenn ich jetzt mit dem gefälschten im
zertifikat irgendwo raus gezogen werde
aus dem verkehr dass ich in ein lager
kommen beispielsweise es ist für für
jemand der außen stehend ist kaum
nachvollziehbar wie emotionalisiert und
wie wie tief die leute in diesem
telegramm sprudel drin hängen und es ist
unheimlich schwierig für die dort auch
wieder rauszukommen
sie lassen auch keine anderen
informationen rein und gleichzeitig
radikalisieren die sich in den nächten
und dass man aber jetzt bei dieser
gruppe bei dieser speziell bei dresden
offline vernetzung eben beobachten kann
sie gehen noch einen schritt weiter sie
treffen sich mittlerweile auch außerhalb
von telegramm das heißt es wird nicht
mehr nur in der virtuellen welt über
über gewaltfantasien mordfantasien sich
ausgetauscht sondern man trifft sich und
bespricht das dort sozusagen und es war
ja auch thema offenbar auf einem dieser
auf einem dieser treffen wie beim
ministerpräsidenten am besten umbringt
also insofern ich halte es unglaublich
gefährlich ja unheimlich gefährlich was
was was dort seit einiger zeit eben
passiert ja ich glaube dass ich greife
jetzt trotzdem mal den kommentar
aufwärmen bei youtube einen kommentar
von jemand jemandem der sich oma kamen
nennt telegramm einfach verantwortlich
machen so was geht gar nicht aber da
vielleicht noch mal die ganz eindeutige
nachfrage bei dir also das ist
vielleicht schon auch tatsächlich etwas
was wir im moment noch unterschätzen
weil offensichtlich wird sich da ja auch
zur richtigen treffen verabredet richtig
genau das ist ja die idee
dass er die idee von diesen offline
vernetzung dass man den schritt
weitergeht nachdem sich eine gruppe eine
relativ feste gruppe in harter kern
gebildet hat dass man rausgeht und
sozusagen wie sag mal sagen wirklich
auch im realen leben eine gruppe bildet
die durchaus auch aktionen bespricht die
also hier in der dresdner im dresdner
fall eben auch über mord spricht
und sicher klar es ist immer so eine
schwierigkeit ich verstehe das auch wenn
man sagt ja telegramm das erstmal das
erstmal eine vernetzungsplattform wo man
ja auch andere gruppen hat
beispielsweise die
oppositionsgruppen aus belarus
journalisten aus belarus ist jetzt nur
ein beispiel was mir gerade einfällt die
die ihre gruppe ebenfalls dort haben und
wo man sagen muss dass die letzte der
letzte weg für die irgendwo zu
kommunizieren aber die schattenseite ist
eben aus meiner sicht dass man
unglücklich ohne probleme eben hass mord
aufrufe dort verbreiten kann und das
sehr effizient und in der ja weit
streuen kann mit einer großen reichweite
vielen dank an ginsel dass du diese
ergebnisse seiner recherche und auch
deine eindrücke und erlebnisse heute mit
uns geteilt hast danken
gerne und auch heute abend ich hatte es
angesprochen gehen also wieder in
mehreren städten menschen auf die straße
ob das jetzt eben ein friedlicher
protest bleibt oder ob das auch wieder
gewaltsam enden könnte das wissen wir
jetzt natürlich zu dem zeitpunkt noch
nicht aber wir haben auf jeden fall
schon mal einen beitrag mit den ersten
bildern von den protesten heute abend
von cornelia schiemenz
saalfeld in thüringen ist heute abend
einer von zahlreichen protesten
deutschlandweit nach einem wochenende wo
vielerorts die demonstrationen gegen die
korona maßnahmen in gewalt ausarteten
die protestler finden sich über
messenger dienste wie telegramm zusammen
oft von rechtsextremen organisiert hier
wird gehetzt zu morden aufgerufen und
hier werden feindes listen geführt
bundesinnenministerium nancy faeser
sucht nach möglichkeiten telegram direkt
zu fassen gegen hetze gewalt und hass im
netz müssen wir entschlossener vorgehen
die bundesministerin hat damit deutlich
gemacht dass das ein schwerpunkt ihrer
politik sein wird die sie jetzt an geht
wo sie mit den experten darüber reden
wird und auch innerhalb der
bundesregierung darüber sprechen wird
was man tun kann um diesem phänomen noch
stärker als bisher zu begegnen das
problem telegram ignoriert bisher alle
aufforderungen sich ein deutsches recht
zu halten der bundesjustizminister sieht
sich dennoch ausreichend gerüstet all
das verstößt heute schon gegen geltende
strafrecht wir haben an dieser stelle
also kein gesetzes- defizit sondern wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass die geltende
rechtslage auch durchgesetzt wird und
das sei ländersache in den ländern hat
man derzeit vor allem mit der
bewältigung der protestwelle zu tun in
sachsen treffen sich menschen an bis zu
70 orten gleichzeitig zu sogenannten
spaziergängen illegal da sich in sachsen
nur zehn menschen zusammenfinden dürfen
demokratie ist ja keine kein zustand
sondern ist eine haltung wir brauchen
auch die zivilgesellschaft denn ich
glaube nur mit polizeilichen mitteln und
nur mit der polizei die panini zu
bekämpfen das wird alleine nicht
ausreichen
in saalfeld laufen zur stunde mehrere
hundert menschen durch die stadt
friedlich
gerade noch ein geräusch auf more jetzt
ist es weg so wir können jetzt über das
thema weiter sprechen mit autorin
katharina nur kuhn sie beschäftigt sich
intensiv mit verschwörungs erzählung und
auch mit der gefahr die von ihnen
ausgeht schönen guten abend frauen nur
cool und außerdem wird neubauer erst
bürgermeister von augustusburg in
sachsen und auch er kann von seinen
erfahrungen ganz persönlich erzählen wie
er mit den widerständen gegen die korona
politikum geht möchte möchte ein anfang
mit frau nur cool wir sprechen jetzt ja
auch über eine zunehmende
radikalisierung die sich zumindest jetzt
am wochenende und auch so schon in den
tagen zuvor beobachten dies kam dass
jetzt plötzlich oder was hat das
vielleicht auch jetzt ein bisschen
beschleunigt dass das jetzt so gekommen
ist
ja man muss sagen dass diese
gewaltspirale sich ja nicht erst seit
neuestem angefangen hat zu drehen
sondern wir haben schon vor einem jahr
in unterschiedlichen einschlägigen
gruppen ähnliche aufrufe gesehen das
heißt es gab immer wieder aufrufe am
einzeln gegen konkrete politik
journalisten oder auch
wissenschaftlerinnen vorzugehen es gab
ja auch gewaltfantasien sie dort geteilt
wurden und von anfang an haben wir eben
auch gesehen dass rechtsextreme
gruppierungen da eine rolle gespielt
haben die abseits der panini schon
vorher sage ich meinen einen gewissen
packs herbeigesehnt haben das heißt es
spielen auch bürgerkriegs fantasien eine
rolle und ja schon den einen oder
anderen akteur aus dieser szene muss man
eben diese demonstration die dort
stattfinden aus dieser perspektive sehen
das heißt es geht gar nicht so sehr
wahrscheinlich für einzelnen gruppen aus
dem rechtsextremen com oder maßnahmen
sondern man sieht eben das als
möglichkeit fenster um eine lang gehegte
fantasie eines gewaltsamen umsturzes
eines bürgerkriegs der ausgelöst werden
könnte umzusetzen weil man sagen muss
das ist vollkommen weltfremd wenn wir
uns die umfragen anschauen ist auch ganz
klar nur ein ganz kleiner teil der
bevölkerung
zahlt überhaupt diese verschwörungs
fantasien die auf entsprechenden
demonstrationen verbreitet werden in
dieser radikalen form jedenfalls
herr neubauer sie sitzen mit
augustusburg in sachsen schon umringt
von städten in denen es auch immer
wieder zu neben demonstrationen kommt
bei ihnen im ort ist es tatsächlich ein
bisschen anders warum ist das bei ihnen
anders warum gibt es bei ihnen stand
jetzt keine demos
also das kann ich ihnen wahrscheinlich
gar nicht
beantworten
ich denke dass wir hier einen guten
diskurs haben und der stadt wir
versuchen das schon sehr lange
eigentlich habe nie aufgehört mit namen
anzureden ich denke dass das was jetzt
hier gerade passiert ihr habt ihr wisst
schon gehört haben ergebnis eines sehr
sehr langen prozesses schon ist von
ausgrenzung von pauschalen ausgrenzung
wir haben halt immer versucht irgendwie
im gespräch zu bleiben vielleicht ist es
dass ich kann es mit bestimmtheit nicht
sagen aber
ich bin fest davon überzeugt dass das
was ich jetzt hier bahn bricht ganz
andere gründe hat als diese pandemie
das steht auf einem breiten sockel von
nicht gehört seien nicht verstanden sein
von alten verletzungen die weit
zurückreichen in zumindest ihre
ostdeutschen geschichte und das ist am
ende genau diese projektionsfläche wie
es wie wir es bei der flüchtlingskrise
hatten also ich sag jetzt mal beinahe
thema egal woran sich dieser protest
vereint das hier ist ja der höhepunkt
einer unfassbaren vertrauenskrise die
dieses land theorie so noch nie gesehen
hat sie sagen ist es wichtig nicht
aufzuhören zu reden frauen jetzt von den
menschen die da teilweise also sich
gewaltbereit zeigen ist mit denen
eigentlich noch zu reden was ist da ja
ihre
einschätzung ihrer erfahrung
ich halte eine klare abgrenzung
tatsächlich für die beste strategie die
man momentan auf politischer ebene
fahren kann dann gruppen sich nicht von
gewalt ab ganzen selbst dazu aufrufen
wenn demonstrationen auch von
rechtsextremen akteuren veranstaltet
werden wenn dort das heißt man leben in
einer diktatur also auch ganz klar ja
fantasie liegen verbreitet werden die
einfach nicht der realität entsprechen
und dann auch auf telekom aufgerufen
wird journalisten zu bebohren dann finde
ich muss auch klar sein dass an der
stelle irgendwo das gespräch dann vorbei
ist weil wenn man dann noch sagt wir
reden auf auf augenhöhe sozusagen diesen
gruppierungen und tun so als wenn das
kein größeres problem der sich in dieser
art und weise zu verhalten dann
normalisiert das eben etwas was in einer
demokratie nicht normalisiert werden
sollte und ich denke man muss ja eben
auch an die opfer von verschwörungs
erzählungen sprechen also es gibt
zahlreiche wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler die in den letzten
monaten massiv bedroht worden sind bis
hin zu drohungen auch die gegen die
familie ausgesprochen wurden und da muss
man einfach sagen an der stelle muss
dann auch ein gespräch vorbei sein herr
neubauer sehen sie das genauso mit ihrer
haltung eigentlich zu sagen das gespräch
darf nie aufhören ja das ist immer so
ein missverständnis
natürlich rede ich auch mit dem nicht
und ich weiß ganz genau dass das man mit
diesen leuten die sich da radikalisiert
haben nicht nicht reden kann dass das
also wirklich auch vergossene milch ist
und dass das auch ausgegrenzt gehört und
glauben sie mir bedrohungssituation
kenne ich mich aus da muss mich niemand
belehrt fakt ist aber eins von diesen
hunderten die da wandern gehen ist das
ein bruchteil und wir müssen uns schon
langsam aber sicher irgendwann die mühe
geben in die differenzierung
einzusteigen und zu gucken wie wir diese
leute die da offensichtlich mit laufen
wieder zurückgewinnen können und das
wird nicht gehen durch mehr druck und
durch ausgrenzung es ist ein fataler
fehler der seit monaten in der politik
vielleicht sogar seit jahren schon
gemacht wird dass man diese große gruppe
versucht pauschal auszugrenzen als nicht
diskussionsfähig als nicht
demokratiefähig das ist ein fehler ich
kann darin wurden wieder aus meiner
ameisen perspektive darauf hinweisen
natürlich ist es schwierig und natürlich
haben wir an harten kern aber dieser
harte kern gehört ausgegrenzt und das
ist vielleicht auch nicht die aufgabe
der bürger aber was wir jetzt brauchen
ist eine völlig andere moral in der
gesellschaft wo ist denn diese große
mehrheit die eigentlich einverstanden
ist dem das genau so gegen den strich
geht dass ihre straßen benutzt werden
das ist jetzt die aufgabe wir müssen
also als gesellschaftliche aufgabe
erkennen das ist etwas was uns doppelt
fordert das kann nicht nur politik und
das kann auch nicht nur auf der polizei
abgeladen werden das ist jetzt aufgabe
einer gesellschaft wir alle lassen sie
uns zu dritt über diese
gesellschaftliche aufgabe gleich noch
sprechen aber vielleicht auch ganz
richtig gesagt zur differenzierung auch
noch mal kurz in einen o-ton vom
thüringischen
georg meyer reinhören der auch nochmal
sich zu diesen verschiedenen
gruppierungen die dort vertreten sind
geäußert hat also wir sehen bei den
initiatoren
oft dass das extremisten sind
rechtsextremisten in der regel aber auch
sogenannte querdenker auch impfgegner
befinden sich darunter also man kann
schon sagen dass im wesentlichen diese
größeren auch die
gewalttätigen demonstrationen aus diesem
bereich kommen aber für mich
unverständnis ich habe volles
verständnis dafür dass menschen sich dem
anschließen in großer zahl das ist
leider so es ist nicht die geeignete
form protest auszuüben
schon vor dem hintergrund der infektions
lager aber auch und gerade vor dem
hintergrund da es sich bei den
initiatoren oft um extremisten
rechtsextremisten handelt
wenn wir jetzt die unterscheidung machen
also wenn wir sagen es gibt die die
extremistische unterwegs sind und es
gibt jene die also vielleicht in dem
falle mit laufen dann vielleicht auch
mit zu wenig wissen darüber mit wem sie
da eigentlich laufen fans angesprochen
herr neubauer indem sie sagten das ist
eine gesellschaftliche aufgabe im wo
sehen sie denn da jetzt wirklich auch
die verantwortung wie sollte am besten
reagiert werden um da eben nicht noch
mehr menschen zu verlieren
also ganz klar ist dass die dass die
gegen den wirklich extremistischen kern
vorgegangen werden muss und da bin ich
sehr dankbar für solche recherchen und
pinsel aber schon viele gute filme
darüber gemacht das muss auch
aufgegriffen werden hat die sächsische
polizei ziemlich lange zugesehen dass
muss man ganz klar sagen da sind dinge
gewachsen die nicht hätten stark werden
dürfen aber wir müssen auf kommunaler
ebene mit dem mit den leuten reden wir
müssen gesprächsangebot machen und sie
fragen warum sie dorthin laufen was das
wirkliche problem ist und damit hat mich
persönlich sehr gute erfahrungen gemacht
und es meint jetzt nicht die vielen
menschen die das schon tun die also
wirklich in den kommentarspalten
gegenhalten die sich jetzt da noch immer
verletzt fühlen sagen was denkt ihr
eigentlich was machen wir den ganzen tag
natürlich seid ihr da aber ihr seid
nicht die masse und das meine ich es
muss in die familien ich will ganz oft
in den familien den kaffee zwischen
diese themen werden ausgespart es gibt
nur streit aber genau dort gehören sie
hin weil wenn ich jemanden noch
erreichen möchte dann sind das dann ist
es wichtig dass das menschen sind auf
der antwort nicht wert lege wir brauchen
die kommunale ebene sehr viel mehr wir
müssen das eben im kollegenkreis wir
müssen begreifen dass wir in einer
sondersituation stecken und das ist
diese und den leuten klar machen dass es
diese verschwörung diesen plan unfassbar
einfach mal nicht gibt und das kann
nicht nur politik und das können wir
auch nicht nur durch durch im pflichten
oder sonst irgendwas regeln sollen wir
müssen jetzt wirklich es schaffen die
leute zu motivieren den mut zu haben
endlich vor die tür zu gehen und paroli
zu bieten und zwar bei den leuten diese
persönlich kennen und das ist eine
aufgabe ich weiß dass das total schwer
ist aber ich habe keine andere idee wie
wir das sonst lösen wollen frauen nun
auch sie haben sich intensiv mit der
frage beschäftigt wie umgehen mit
verschwörerischen verschwörungs
gläubigen als langes wort also auch im
privaten wie kann man denn diese
menschen überhaupt noch erreichen
zunächst einmal würde ich das voll und
ganz unterschreiben oder schreiben
wollen dass es wichtig ist im privaten
eben nicht einfach schweigend immer
solche aussagen hinwegzugehen bei
schweigen wird viel zu oft eben als
zustimmung gewertet
und wir wissen eben auch aus der
psychologischen forschung das ist ein
unterschied macht wie schnell menschen
intervenieren das heißt wenn jemand noch
nicht sehr gefestigt ist in seinem
verschwörungs glauben und man dann
beispielsweise auf basis eines
faktenchecks argumentiert kann man
jemanden noch ganz gut zurück wollen
sage ich mal wenn man das aber ein paar
monate laufendes bis es irgendwann so
radikal in den aussagen wird dass man
sagt jetzt kann ich nicht mehr schweigen
dann ist es meist ja fast schon zu spät
oder deutlich schwieriger zumindest und
beratungsstellen am raten vor allem dazu
bleiben sie im gespräch das heißt um
setzten sie sich in einer diskussion
nicht unbedingt das ziel ich muss
jemanden jetzt in einer stunde über
zweiten sondern denken sie sich immer
der stetige tropfen höhlt den stein das
heißt es ist schon ein erfolg wenn ich
bei jeder diskussion einen guten punkt
reinbringen zweifel sehe oder auch eine
gute frage stellen es kann aber auch
sein dass man irgendeinen gut dann
seinem ergebnis kommt der andere hört
mir gar nicht mehr zu und da muss man
sich klar machen dass fakten eben nur
ein teil der debatte sind ja also auf zu
spielen
schon da auch eine große rolle wir
wissen aus der forschung das
verschwörungs erzählungen sich sehr
geschickt an ihr habt sicher logische
grundbedürfnisse an wochen können die
wir alle irgendwo haben also wer möchte
nicht das gefühl haben man ist einer der
wenigen sozusagen den durchblick hat ja
also man ist irgendwie soll ich mal
cleverer als die anderen und genau
dieses gefühl geben einem verschwörungs
erzählungen ja oder vielleicht auch
anschluss an eine soziale gruppe
selbstwirksamkeit erfahrung und da kann
man ruhig mal einen schritt zurückgehen
und sich fragen mehr warum möchte der
andere daran glauben ja was ist
vielleicht auch die gesamtsituation in
der umgebung im umfeld im familiären
privaten bereich auch im beruflichen
gibt vielleicht auch probleme die da
eine rolle spiele und da versuchen diese
bedürfnisse die durch diese gruppe die
durch die verschwörungs erzählungen
geschrieben werden auf eine gesunde art
und weise zu befriedigen und ich kannte
im vergleich mit sekten im vorherigen
gespräch da auch sehr passend weil
tatsächlich ist es so dass man sich hier
also auch gerne an beratungsstellen
wenden kann gibt es bundesweit und vor
allem sekten beratungsstellen sind da
auch wirklich eine gute anlaufstelle die
haben teilweise eine vervierfachung
verfünffachung der anfragen im letzten
jahr gehabt und die können auch sehr
gute hilfestellungen dazu geben wie man
in solchen situationen auch langfristig
damit umgehen kann und man muss sich
einfach klarmachen es ist möglich
menschen aus diesen gruppierungen
rauszuholen war sie zu überzeugen das
ist aber oft eben ein langer und
mühevoller prozess und natürlich ist es
auch wichtig sich da immer wieder klar
zu machen es ist okay wenn ich
zwischendurch eine pause einlegen und
das ist auch notwendig dass man irgendwo
auch grenzen zieht dass man
beispielsweise sagt wenn die mir immer
nicht zu gast bei diskussionen wenn ich
nicht ausreden lässt wenn wir laut
werden wenn nämlich bestimmt dann ist
das einfach nicht die art und weise wie
wir miteinander gut ins gespräch kommen
können und da und wir für sich auch rote
linien ziehen und klipp und klar ganz
eindeutig auch bei rassismus
antisemitismus nicht einfach darüber
hinweggehen sondern dass ganz klar
adressieren und sagen hey ist verstößt
einfach gegen grundlegende werte an die
ich wichtig finde und von denen ich
eigentlich auch dachte dass musik
wichtig finden ist und das ist nicht in
ordnung dass du so etwas verbreitet ist
ich möchte gerne kommentare mal aus dem
stream hier auch mit dazu nehmen und
zwar maximal schreibt bei youtube wie
wäre es mal stuhlkreis querdenker
bekommen hälfte der stühle und politiker
die andere hälfte so funktioniert sorgen
ernst nehmen und überzeugungsarbeit ich
glaube herr neubauer sie gehen ja direkt
in den dialog ich weiß nicht ob im
stuhlkreis aber das ist ja auf jeden
fall ihre devise es gibt hier noch mehr
kommentare von jack walsh bei youtube
vielleicht ist das verhalten der
demonstranten auch ausdruck der
hilflosigkeit gegenüber den politischen
entscheidungen und noch ein letzter
bevor wir weiter sprechen von bob marley
er sich nennt bei youtube friedlich
demonstrieren ist natürlich okay dass
wegen der hohen infektionszahlen oftmals
keine demonstration möglich sind und die
teilnehmer keine maske tragen und keine
abstand halten ist halt ein problem die
wut und den hass an polizisten
auszulassen ist ebenfalls sehr fraglich
da hilft nur klare kante herr neubauer
klare kante als stichwort es gab jetzt
auch kritik immer wieder an der polizei
sich da bei demos entweder es gab zum
einen den vorwurf sich zu sehr mit den
gegendemonstranten beschäftigt zu haben
und die andere seite wegen zu wenig zu
beachtet zu haben oder eben auch nicht
vor ort zu sein wie erleben sie das in
der region wo ja auch augustusburg wiegt
die er nehmen sie denn da die polizei
bei jetzt auch demonstrationen
ja es ist manchmal
unverhältnismäßig eskortieren also
freiberg wir dass er sehr oft gesehen
habe ich auch selber ein paar mal
gesehen dass die polizei einfach mit
lief quasi wir haben hier kleinere
veranstaltung habe das schon eine ganze
weile her allerdings protest gegen das
testen von kindern daran da war die
polizei über reaktiv also wir hatten da
teilweise mehr polizisten als
teilnehmerin der veranstaltung
also das spannend sehr das hat keine
wirkliche linie erst so in den letzten
tagen kann man zu ahnen dass man ist
jetzt wirklich ernst meint mal gerade zu
rücken wurde das gewaltmonopol in diesem
staat liegt das ist auch ein gutes
signal
aber am ende muss man halt immer wieder
sagen wir bekämpfen gerade das symptom
bekämpfte das was wir sehen und ich
denke wir brauchen eine andere politik
wir müssen tatsächlich leute mehr
beteiligen wir brauchen auch eine
größere stärkere beteiligung in der
gesamtpolitik der kommunen das ist in
diesen zeiten in dem menschen so stark
vernetzt sind wo sehr viele diskussionen
gibt sehr viel mehr anders als das
vielleicht noch vor 20 jahren
es ist unerlässlich wir sind ja
erlebnisraum dass die kommune ist der
demokratische erlebnisraum wenn man
politik an uns vorbei macht und das ist
im freistaat sachsen der fall dann ist
dass am ende das ergebnis es gibt einen
wahnsinnigen vertrauensverlust zwischen
politik und bürgern hier und dieser
vertrauensvolle spricht sich immer
wieder bahn das war wie ich kann mich
nur wiederholen die flüchtlingskrise für
viele menschen sind das ventile das ist
der gemeinsame nenner ist dann dieser
proteste hat er meint eigentlich was
völlig anderes und wenn wir das ändern
wollen dann müssen wir auch die politik
ein sondern das ist die wirkliche
aufgabe müssen diese klaren strategien
kommt die menschen nachvollziehen können
und wir müssen vielleicht auch mal
fehler zugeben also tatsächlich sind ja
auch fehler passiert aber mein gott das
ist eine pandemie er konnte keinen mit
irgendetwas planen aber was die leute
wollen ist eine klare führung wenn ich
heute auch wie gestern der zeit gelesen
den satz von von gauck wer haben
anspruch auf gute führung das ist
tatsächlich auch ein punkt und das nimmt
letzter satz das nimmt auch
kommunalpolitiker mit in die pflicht ich
sehe dass viele ordnen dass stadträte
ortschaftsräte teilweise auch kollegen
viel zu leise sind ich finde wir dürfen
uns unsere marktplatz oder zur straße
nicht wegnehmen lassen von einer von
einer von einer von einer minderheit die
versucht menschen zu verletzen und das
ist doch eine aufgabe und die kann man
ganz klar um reisen die betrifft uns
alle das kann man lösen und das ist
gesellschaftlich untermauert und wir
werden sehen dass da viel vertrauen auf
kommunaler ebene da ist dass man dadurch
menschen mobilisieren kann im positiven
fall in freiburg kann man das sehr schön
sehen mit der initiative freiberg für
alle haben jetzt in offenen brief
gestattet man den zustand vor
dreieinhalb tausend unterschriften es
ist wahrscheinlich schon längst überholt
das geht und das brauchen wir jetzt ist
keine politische aufgabe jetzt ist die
gesellschaft gefordert zu sagen wir
wollen den konsens und wir wollen euch
nicht wollen uns nicht bestimmen lassen
von einer kaffee minderheit
der städte und gemeindebund warnt vor
gewalt gegenüber kommenden
kommunalpolitikerinnen und politikern
glauben sieht dass da nicht vielleicht
auch eben einige kolleginnen und
kollegen eben durch morddrohungen und
ähnliches fackeln vor der haustüre
eben dadurch besonders 1 geschichte sind
und dass es dann vielleicht auch
manchmal schwer fällt laut zu bleiben
natürlich kann ich das verstehen also
das ist natürlich eine sondersituation
und ich glaube ganz menge die die leute
die das schon erlebt haben hier leider
muss man sagen aber in so einer
stadtgesellschaft wenn man das
kommuniziert mit den leuten redet das
sagt herd und gibt es noch nie gegen
antwort ich kann mich erinnern ich hatte
das vor zwei jahren ich habe da mit
wenigen leuten darüber gesprochen und es
gab eine gute reaktion in der
gesamtstadt gesagt hier passiert ja
nichts und das macht natürlich auch hier
noch was mit gemeinschaften werden
menschen auch achtsamer für das thema
und ich glaub tatsächlich überall dort
wo das funktioniert haben ist kein platz
für radikale und ich denke das ist ich
bin überzeugt davon dass der großteil
der menschen mag man dem den crooner
maßnahmen zustimmen oder nicht machen
mag man sich verstehen oder nicht das
ist alles zweites mag man das impfen
glauben oder nicht ist das ist auch noch
mal zweiter fakt aber ist doch dass alle
verstehen müssen dass wir jetzt eine
wichtige situation haben und dass diese
gesellschaft zusammenrücken muss um ihre
werte zu verteidigen unsere gemeinsamen
werte und das können wir uns doch nicht
von radikalen einfach so wegnehmen
lassen und dann können wir gerne darüber
reden was wir falsch gemacht haben und
was man vielleicht anders machen kann
noch die frage an sie frau diese
feindbilder dass da also auch
politikerinnen und politiker auf
kommunaler ebene zu den feindbildern
gemacht werden woher kommt sowas ja
man muss sagen dass so gut wie jeder
verschwörungs erzählung anja bestimmte
bausteine auch zugrunde liegen und wir
sehen eben ganz häufig dass da auch so
eine gewisse immunisierung strategie mit
eingebaut ist das heißt sobald menschen
von außen kritisieren sei es aus der
wissenschaft aus den medien oder eben
auch aus der politik werden sie auch
schnell in die verschwörungs erzählung
als mutmaßliche verschwörer eingebaut ja
und dann führt das eben auch zu so einer
gewissen eigendynamik dass man menschen
auch so viele faktenchecks vorlegen kann
man möchte solange derjenige glaubt der
faktencheck wer von verschwörern bezahlt
worden als beispiel wird dass sie
wahrscheinlich nicht lesen und deshalb
ist es auch durchaus schwierig wenn man
beispielsweise sagt man möchte davon
politischer ebene im gespräch auf
augenhöhe führen weil man sich immer
klar machen muss der andere sieht mich
vielleicht durch eine ganz andere brille
ja also der andere glaubt vielleicht
dass ich sozusagen eine marionette von
dahinterstehenden mächten bilden das ich
von irgendjemandem bezahlt bin dass ich
ja vielleicht daran beteiligt bin
irgendwie kinder umzubringen das sind
wirklich an diese dramatischen activity
teilweise auch telekom verbreitet werden
und mit einem feind möchte man nicht
diskutieren dann möchte man keinen
kompromiss finden sondern menschen so
etwas glauben ja dass ist eine
diskussion an der stelle auch nicht mehr
zielführend weil ein feind der möglichen
mehr bekämpft und das ist eben das große
problem und gerade auf kommunaler ebene
kann es eben ja sie haben es schon
angesprochen diese einschüchterung auch
dazu führen dass vielleicht gute leute
nicht noch einmal für eine nächste
amtszeit kandidieren gerade auf lokaler
ebene sehen wir auch immer wieder dass
ein teleplan truppen auch vorlagen
verbreitet werden für protestschreiben
auch teilweise für juristische
klageandrohung und gerade auf kommunaler
ebene sind oftmals jap menschen in der
politik die verunsichert dadurch sind ja
also wenn man sich mal vorstellen man
bekommt plötzlich so massen mailings und
man denkt hinter jedem medium steht
jetzt ein bürger aus meinem wahlkreis
dann ist man natürlich verunsichert
fakt ist aber man muss sich da auch klar
machen dass es immer wieder organisierte
aktionen gibt mit denen das menü auch
versucht sich größer darzustellen als es
eigentlich ist und ja es für mich schon
mehrfach gesagt in der sendung die
schweigende mehrheit die dahinter steht
ist ja eigentlich eine mehrheit die sagt
wir finden einen infektionsschutz gut
wir haben uns impfen lassen das darf man
ja auch nicht vergessen an jedem
einzelnen tag werden gerade mehr
menschen geimpft und mustert als jemals
bei querdenken protesten bundesweit vor
ort fahren das ist die mehrheit ganz
eindeutig ich möchte trotzdem wir müssen
langsam zum ende kommen aber zum schluss
weil ich mehrfach in den kommentaren
gelesen habe an sie frau nur noch eine
frage in richtung telegramm stellen und
eben der radikalität dort und ich nehme
jetzt eine als beispiel und zwar von
lissy es bei youtube gibt es zahlen zur
radikalität wie viele mensch wurden
radikal zählt der gebrauch von telegramm
bereits als radikal
der hat telegramm ist erstmal eine
plattform und sie kann für
unterschiedliche zwecke genutzt werden
ja also wir wissen eben das im ausland
auch ganz andere gruppierungen telekom
nutzen wie beispielsweise
oppositionsgruppierungen in weißrussland
oder eben auch demokratie freundliche
bewegung in deutschland haben wir die
spezielle situation dass schon vor kuba
vor allem rechtsextreme gruppierungen
sehr stark auf programm gesetzt haben
das heißt es gab dort akteure und große
kanäle die eben vorher schon existiert
waren und ich brauche ja schon nicht
klein waren und klar ist auch dass mit
einer zunehmenden ja auch durch
setzungen von geltendem recht auf
anderen plattformen da auch eine gewisse
abwanderung stattgefunden hat das heißt
es gab auch mal als akteure die auf
großen plattformen aktiv waren und die
aber immer dafür geworben haben wer wann
willst dass ich mal irgendwo klartext
redet das kann ich nicht machen dann
musst du mir auf telegramm folgen und
insgesamt muss man aber sagen teleplan
ist streng genommen ja auch kein reiner
messenger also man darf das nicht
verwechseln beispielsweise mit anderen
plattformen weil bei teleplan spielt
eine sehr große rolle dass wir dort
diese großen kanäle haben wo teilweise
deutlich mehr als 100.000 leute mit
wesen das hat eher den charakter eines
sozialen netzwerks ist und schon da
hoffentlich ist das auch angemessen das
ist derzeit ja auch in der politik eine
diskussion gibt in die fertige inwiefern
die regeln die auch für soziale
netzwerke gelten eben bei diesen
öffentlichen kanälen aufteilen wo auch
jeder mitlesen kann ja also wir die
leute auch teilweise mit richtigen namen
hetzen ob das dann nicht besser
durchgesetzt werden und man muss auch
ganz klar sagen ich sehe ich ja auch
eine deutliche lücke in der durchsetzung
von recht denn wenn man sich anschaut
akteure wie attila hildmann die haben
unter echtem namen auf ihren kanälen auf
telegramm gehetzt und trotzdem konnte
attila hildmann sich ins ausland
absetzen
bevor
irgendwelche rechtlichen konsequenzen
auf ihn zugekommen sind und so etwas
darf einfach nicht passieren weil das
ist ja ein ganz fatales signal an die
szene nach dem motto wir können so etwas
machen und kommt auch noch ungestraft
davon immer telegramm sehe ich schon von
den kommentaren hier könnten wir auch
wirklich noch mal einer anderen sendung
sprechen aber ganz zum schluss nochmal
zurück von der online in die in die face
to face welt und zwar noch einen
kommentar den ich hier gerne vorlesen
möchte von halligalli bei youtube oh je
ich habe es versucht mit diskussionen
ihr glaubt ja gar nicht wie man da
angefeindet wird am ende wird man aus
dem haus geworfen herr neubauer was
machen sie was ist ihr tipp am ende
vielleicht dieser sendung damit man
nicht aus dem haus geworfen wird wie
also im gespräch bleiben wie machen sie
es
naja das ist nicht einfach das wissen
wir glaube ich alle und es gibt ja viele
die sich der tapfer ins gefecht gegeben
ich kann nur immer wieder mut machen
kann zeigt ein gespräch ist umsonst das
fällt schon mal gesagt ich sage das auch
immer wieder jedes gespräch zeigt dem
anderen eine andere sichtweise auf aber
das möchte oder nicht spielt überhaupt
keine rolle er nimmt was mit und ich
habe hier lange gesprächsfäden der stadt
geführt die nicht umsonst waren also
lasst uns das wirklich gemeinsam machen
wir müssen da jetzt durch das braucht
uns alle
dann bis hierhin vielen dank an
katharina nun an an die autorin
katharina nur cool und andreas neubauer
bürgermeister von augustusburg in
sachsen danke danke schön danke und
danke auch an euch für die
aufmerksamkeit natürlich für die fragen
und kommentare und wir bleiben an dem
thema dran und bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]